on débrief avec vous alexis blanc vous
avez suivi cette allocution on retiendra
notamment que vendre département du nord
de l'ile-de-france de l'est et du
sud-est sont placés sous surveillance
renforcée jean castex lance des
concertations locales avec les élus
concernés avant l'annoncé de mesures qui
pourraient entrer en vigueur le week-end
du 6 mars
oui c'est ça il prépare en fait les
esprits peut-être un plus de confinement
localisés comme c'est le cas déjà à nice
et à dunkerque le week-end il a encore
une fois pris la parole pour ne pas dire
grand cho jean castex juste dire que
voilà
le gouvernement fait son boulot ça
marche bien on est content et que ça va
être encore plus dur puisque malgré un
ses efforts ça reste compliqué et qu'il
faudra voir la semaine prochaine donc
c'est on reprend un peu le rythme dont
on avait pris l'habitude conseil de
défense le mercredi conseil des
ministres et puis jean castex le jeudi
pour dire on verra la semaine prochaine
et si jamais vraiment ça s'enraye alors
ce sera peut-être autour d' emmanuel
macron de prendre la parole ça c'était
les séquences de communication
coronavirus qu'on a vu par le passé ça a
visiblement a repris avec cette fois ci
plus de de données quand même sur cette
campagne de vaccination qui a commencé
on reste quand même très loin du compte
1 par rapport aux chiffres annoncés avec
un 2 97% de la population qui a reçu
deux injections de ces vaccins avec
certes des chiffres commençaient à être
encourageants notamment venant d'israël
comme le disait alain fischer mais
encore une fois c'est une étude de court
terme donc il faudra voir sur le long
terme ce qu'il en est besoin de ses
courbes donc voilà une conférence de
presse une fois de plus pour faire un
point d'étape en disant c'est pas fini
alors jean castex dit qu'il comprend que
les français commencent à être
extrêmement là c'est la lassitude
ça fait plus d'un an que nous sommes
empêtrés dans ce qu un virus et cette
gestion étrange de creed je ne sais pas
s'il prend l'ampleur finalement de cette
lassitude c'est vrai que les français
sont à la fois patient et qu'il essaie
de faire du mieux que possible compte
tenu de cette vie sous cloche qui leur
est imposée depuis plus d'un an jean
castex a défendu
la stratégie de ne par confiner au plan
national il faut tout faire pour
retarder un confinement c'est ce qu'il a
dit à ce qu'ils appellent un confinement
du régime bédié il a répondu que c'était
loin d'être aussi simple et la mise en
avant l'économie et l'éducation des
élèves
oui évidemment alors il ya tout d'une
question parce que clairement il y à
débat sur la réalité sanitaire du
confinement est ce que ça sert vraiment
à quelque chose est ce que ça fait une
grosse différence ou pas et les études
sont contradictoires
donc pourquoi vouloir à tout prix
confiné si ça ne fonctionne pas et puis
on voit d'ailleurs les pays autour de
nous qui on reçoit zee de fermer les
écoles de confier bien les chiffres ne
sont pas forcément meilleurs que ceux de
la france ou tout ça est vraiment dans
un mouchoir de poche donc la question de
ces mesures non sanitaires de privation
des libertés commence à faire débat et
il est temps parce que effectivement on
peut se poser la question de la raison
de ces mesures alors le problème c'est
où sont les poches de contamination et
c'est vrai que les écoles ont été
montrés du doigt comme étant un des
lieux où on peut évidemment se
contaminer puisque difficile de faire
les gestes barrière difficile d'aérer
avec tes le peu de moyens d'ailleurs
pour été donnée aux professeurs et à
l'éducation nationale les transports en
commun bien entendu la question des
aéroports où là encore cette vue est ce
qu'avec des tests pcr mais pas forcément
tout le temps enfin ça dépend de vous
arriver
la question des frontières qui s'est
posée et à laquelle le maquereau n'a pas
vraiment répondu
l'allemagne à elle choisi de fermer
certaines frontières elle a été rappelée
à l'ordre par par bruxelles en dix ans
dont on ne fait pas ça quand on est dans
schengen alors tout est compliqué et
tout est contradictoire et c'est ce qui
fait que finalement la lassitude est
présente et qu'on ne comprend plus à
quoi tout cela sert finalement à part à
dire que on est encore loin du compte en
termes de la livraison des vaccins du
nombre de vaccinations et puis olivier
ferrand ce soir qui qu'enfin parle de
des traitements et pas seulement des
vaccins parce que il semblerait que
l'objectif un des vaccins ne sera pas
atteint compte tenu de la difficulté
qu'ont les laboratoires à produire
même si certains labos utilisent leur
facilité production tour pour d'autres
la bo donc on va commencer à parler des
traitements hors lol il est des rangs
effectivement parle de traitement assez
cher assez assez spéciaux mais efficace
mais c'est une bonne chose de voir qu'il
ya d'autres solutions que la seule
solution ce n'est pas la vaccination
c'en est une mais loin loin de là il ya
les les traitements précoces il ya aussi
des traitements lourds à base de deux
lentilles l'onu guillaume je sais plus
exactement quels termes techniques mais
qui a été annoncé par olivier verrou
pour terminer très rapidement alexis
poule en revenons un instant sur la
stratégie vaccinale et la campagne de
vaccination à la fin de ce mois de
février se font au plus de 4 millions de
vaccins qui auront été administré à près
de trois millions de personnes selon
jean castex est ce que aujourd'hui la
france a rattrapé son retard même si se
pose la question
des délais de livraison des prochains
vaccins alors il ya eu un effort de fait
dès effectivement
la france n'a pas vraiment rattraper son
retard même si la montée en puissance de
la vaccination a eu lieu comme s'était
dit le problème c'est la pénurie de
livraison puisque les labos paint et à
produire assez de doses pour tout le
monde et que on est loin du compte si
emmanuel macron avait parlé de faire de
ce vaccin bien commun de l'humanité bien
c'est pas du tout le cas dans les fêtes
la france n'a pas voté pour pousser le
msa à sortir une mesure qui permettrait
aux états effectivement d'imposer aux
laboratoires de rendre dans le domaine
public leur solution
donc on reste encore totalement
tributaire de laboratoires étrangers
pour la plupart américains pour beaucoup
pour ces vaccins avec une campagne de
vaccination où c'est encore long pour
avoir un rendez vous et où le temps
entre les deux doses pose encore soucis
avec bien sûr comme le disait alain
fischer des vaccins qui ont mauvaise
presse comme astrazeneca à cause des
réactions qu'on était assez forte pour
certains soignants à cause aussi du fait
que ce vaccin ne protégerait pas aussi
efficacement que les autres contre les
variants qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux variant sud-africain marion
brésilien est donc une certaine
réticence à avoir ce vaccin plutôt qu'un
autre
donc là encore un casse tête avec des
chiffres pour dire que ça avance alors
peut-être pas aussi vite que prévu mais
ça avance mais ça n'empêche pas
malheureusement le gouvernement
d'envisager toujours ces mesures
ubuesque que d'amande à 18 heures de
couvre feu de 18h d'autorisation de
sortie de couvre feu le week end
tout ça sans queue ni tête finalement
alors qu'il faudrait mettre le paquet
bien sûr sur la vaccination mais là
encore une fois l'état français ne peut
pas grand chose puisque nous n'avons pas
les moyens de production sur notre sol
merci beaucoup pour votre décryptage
alexis blanc voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire
de cette conférence de presse